honestly just like close your eyes and
point like who do you think is like the
gayest person here close your eyes okay
we all close your eyes we're all going
to point nobody look and then we'll look
when the video comes out yeah yeah yeah
okay you guys are doing this to me right
now yeah be honest okay and then when
you're done I can't wait to watch this
video no head up St up okay okay put
your head down put your thumb up and
I'll walk around the he's going to touch
my thumb let talk I don't want to do
this
anymore he's walking over
here oh God damn it bar touched your
thumb right yeah all
right [__] we have to decide who it was
because only they know if first he has
to describe why he thinks they're gay I
can't there's a reason there's a very
specific reason how come no one else is
just a little sad right
now how how come I'm the one I'm the
only one in the room that's a little
sad everyone in the comments you guys
decide why you guys decide why I
everyone decide why it's me